hello player can you hear me okay
try changing volume it's really
important that you hear me
okay all right one two Mic Check hello
you can hear me now yes hey did you
notice the subtitles it's actually me
typing them as I speak Wow it's killer
no I can't even tell with my eyes closed
so how did I do badly okay let's
continue whenever you are ready
okay all right I didn't now haven't even
said the game hello everybody my name is
markiplier and welcome to dude stop now
this game is a fully released version of
a game that I played on gamejolt a while
back by the same name basically the
entire objective of the game is to not
do what the guy tells you to do
basically if you remember the Stanley
parable you had free choice there we're
in this game you have free choice as
well and the only way to explain it is
to participate in my test you're welcome
just follow my instructions and all will
be fine you can click start now what if
I don't go on no you can't just click OK
I don't even know what a click is just
click it myself no no ok read the rules
and do not proceed without me cuz you're
gonna break something
uh-huh ok I am 28 years old I'm an adult
okay hmm
[Music]
nothing what I looked away for 10
seconds you already smashed it
what are you even doing here you were
supposed to wait on the previous screen
I bet there - fine I'll draw a new vase
just don't proceed without me I bet that
something would have happened all so
just just sit tight and don't click
anything okay so what happens if I
actually wait how long I supposed to
wait do I have to go play another game
before I'm able to continue or whatever
I'm bored I have a TD I can't stand here
forever that's me this is sexual
something like sexual why not know if
I'm getting sexual this from a book what
no I'm not doing that I mean this is
gonna play nice everybody does fine fine
I'm stop pushing I'm in Oh
let me get back to the player
tester hi hello I don't know what you
were talking about there but say hello
okay right yeah yeah that's me they call
me player
mark a player oh hey no I just made a
bet that you gonna be nice and you
already lost on every puzzle so far I
didn't even know there's a way to win
I'd bleed nice if you told me how yeah
15 people before you and they all did
well 15 don't you dare be some sort of
us their shoes snowflake and ruin the
game for me that's me I'm the special
snowflake hello I'm here for my special
snowflake thing what is it I don't know
what I just got but I got something are
you planning something I did it did I do
it did is there not it the arrow it's
supposed to
I see how it goes
you're not gonna play by the rules are
you great
great that's what I get big too trusting
I could have tried to test it all by
myself but no I needed to invite you I
didn't get invited
what was the bet what kind of sexual
deviancy do you have to do oh you're
gonna ruin everything
laugh with me and then read a
walkthrough online just to find the best
way to be the worst you're not doing
that not in my game you nasty piece of
okay well there's no need to be that
rude my goodness with your tude
my dude you need to get some therapy
okay all right game over it in how about
no wait am I too harsh on you yes maybe
you just didn't know what to do my
emotions on your keyboard that's also
true yep I was an accident my mama told
me don't take it personally it's just
you did bad and I want to discourage you
from doing that again so uh about that
about the discouragement thing why would
you go whoa I got a trash cup me too man
you and me we're gonna be best buds
before you even know it before you even
realize all your mistakes that you've
made up until this point you're gonna
you and me we're gonna be best buds what
why are the Paxson locking that's a bug
so click better go and watch the credits
yeah that'd be nice okay all right if
you hadn't said anything I wouldn't have
known about it I'm gonna watch the
credits I'm all about supporting the
developers team by half beard
two halves of the beard two and a half
beards two and a half men beards hello
again I'm here wool that's a lot of
that's a lot of cups jigsaw pack finish
the jigsaw puzzle to unlock this oh
those are the things that I was finding
those are pieces of a jigsaw oh there's
so many choices oh so I get to see it
all okay I'll do I'll do some I'll be
nice I mean you know bad bad only good
good that means only good good art
simple should be an easy solution for
you
you knew Oh pointless tasks but I saw
anyway here is your cup shut up just so
you know achievements and jigsaw pieces
are saved automatically as you collect
them so even if you exit the pack you'll
still have them great good to know oh I
want to go back oh that was a good start
alright good did shock and Sam maybe in
your country what's wrong with that
what's wrong with socks Andale
I missed the jigsaw to listen oh and
give it a push I'm so excited yay I
think she's a fall it's not gonna change
the ingame font I removed that feature I
like collaboration I do
I like sans-serif fonts okay this is the
finish line just one more mm-hmm
no the element that's a photo which is
nice of course but you need to film it
why I'll do it but only because you
asked me nicely expected okay cool yes
yes that's how you're supposed to play
and for the lats you deserve a trophy
I've sent it to you by mail it should
arrive shortly any minute now and my
house are in the game sit I don't know
you sent it so like how are you not good
where's my trophy uh have you played any
good games recently I'm some casual
point-and-click puzzles maybe I don't
know if I want to but here I go how did
you it's a penis there's something else
I keep going
oh did you fit that in there oh that's
for my mother-in-law the next one must
be your cuff
how many penis light things can you fit
in an envelope oh here you go
I got a long cup that's what they all
say
great you know I was scared after the
first pack but now playing like that
you'll have no problem unlocking the
rest of the get wait why is it still
locked it should have this is weird
it is weird or I'm gonna go back in and
be an [ __ ]
there's your talk puzzle piece right in
the corner yeah okay man I shown you the
correct spot yeah but I put in there
what here but right here oh gosh I don't
know how letters work people don't I
really have to send letters anymore
remember singing is bad sinning is not
swear them ever heard of a butterfly
effect no that's the wrong way
oh well too bad for you good thing I'm
an [ __ ]
she's a font on his hands it's really
it's not unpopular if anything Comic
Sans is more popular than it's ever been
in its life beauty quickly filming no
filming I'm filming it's a photo if I
take enough pictures it'll turn into a
movie don't you know how movies work Oh
about upside dune there we go if you
look at it upside down then it smiles if
you look at it the normal way then it's
frowned I want a double smile not a
double frown Oh what is this
hmm here's your prize see I'm timeand
oh you're hard-working the pack watch
closely
is on the left okay now shuffling
shuffling shuffling where no not this
one here this one either here I lied
it's not a diamond of course it's not a
diamond you are ruining my game why
would it be a diamond oh it's so funny
you should have seen your face frickin
face you have a face full of punch if
you keep that up
[ __ ] boots I got a tiny cup for my
tiny dogs anyway no not yet
let me unlock you a pack I need you to
pass some tests I'm a cure stay here I'm
gonna do things here I know there's
puzzle pieces that I haven't seen you
didn't pick me I picked you that's how
buying games works
you got it okay I'll show you I don't
but I assume I do did I do
okay I'm gonna be super nice I'm gonna
nicest right lamb perfectly you got it
you got it you got that that's what I'm
here for baby body baby boo I could get
nine well right except for would you
suggest the game to your friends no not
yet anyway
I do that at the end that's how you
succeed by doing good deeds in a video
game yeah it seems about right that's
gotta be pretty far in my life hey I did
it
I think I don't know what I did but I
did it did I get a new cup did I do is
it there we go so what's this one all
about go somewhere do something and you
will certainly get it well I don't know
what that is song to move on hello lost
cause born to be dumb F is for failure
goal of education no time to explain
let's go in and out twenty-second exam
okay before starting let me tell you a
story and then they died one piggy made
a house out of and died second piggy
stole a bunch of bird eggs and regretted
it and then he died the third was dead
all the time I got em puzzles well you
know what
piggies don't get to play my game come
on Nicky what a coincidence I have a
little test right here to see if you are
one of them and don't even bother asking
me I'm just gonna judge Sully from that
corner
I have a mental age of seven but I am
very very old wiggle waggle wiggle
wiggle
oh my god do I deny the truth or do I
give him the lie that he's comfortable
with I demand the truth which of the
following is correct
oh I'm just vaccinations really cause
autism um obviously oh the truth of the
world is controlled by okay this is just
a fact yes it's absolutely true okay all
right oh the world is not ruled by
lizard people then how do you explain
the suck see you're I'm Zelda name is
for a boy or for a girl it's for either
who are you to judge okay all right so
the following is allowed to do if you
were playing with you didn't via social
media job one ah would you believe that
Illuminati control everything even games
oh hey are your results
you failed no worries
you can still participate in the
ceremony yay wahoo
whoa ha yeah ha
hey oh ho and here comes your future
take it and all have
number twelve to go thank you
I'm assuming you're saying I'm working
at McDonald's but uh joke's on you
McDonald tires from within it's working
the test is working I'm right you're
wrong the rest of the game is looked at
you are out of here
not necessarily I'm gonna go back in
again oh just shush shush your beautiful
mouth watch this how old am i oh yeah
you got it
oh this perfect you got it no yeah oh no
I guess whatever all right let's see
your Apple girl whatever little anything
else and you did well
you passed the exam congratulations
great job
Oh beaters no I'm not any human winner
shed of common sense should be able to
pass this exam so don't get too excited
but good job on being normal
thank you Oh it's called a mortarboard
cap I didn't know that that's you're
learning good work thank you keep going
like this and we can win that bet I
thought I think I was actually thinking
about using the duck on you what's the
does s it that would be target about the
sock we're talking about the duck
you're gonna use the suck on me 22nd I'm
gonna go again
Oh what were you trying to earn extra
points for being fast well I forgot to
start my stopwatch oops
never mind I'll evaluate you now oh wow
okay all right thank you very much for
that [ __ ]
but I did it I did it right did I get it
you're gonna make me do it again I'm
gonna do it again
me got the stopwatch again
oh boy all right shut up I'm gone again
just cuz you're an [ __ ] doesn't mean
that I'm gonna give up okay okay fine
here you go and now I'm gonna grade you
okay
but what about what about what about the
star what about the star for doing it
fast I did it fast can I have it
oh there we go that feels good that
feels real good
alright pack five three puzzle pieces
okay alright you've probably seen it in
the trailer right and they keep on the
Internet no green means go thanks man
thank you
thank you I feel good about the concept
five pieces one box watching you now I
watched two girls one cup I'm pretty
sure I know how this goes and then don't
go good oh yeah or they update real life
too right yeah right why do you gotta
bring in my real life above right shut
up right [ __ ] shut up
right are you just gonna right right hey
shut up god damn okay meet Zach you can
play yes oh I'm the best oh oh there we
go
you happy with me you happy I seek your
approval about putting stuff in the
boxes it's like a theme here okay I got
this one I know how it goes
this one's looking a bit more war this
one's looking a bit more violent than
the other ones I just gotta say alright
let's shove red back in here
excuse me no you wanted to do something
fun but don't worry it'll be possible
later in the game I don't like the sound
of that I'm only gonna draw penises I
know myself it's just the way the world
works when I'm involved at your trick
I'm gonna make this line disappear
[Music]
it's gone I did it I don't know what I
did but you did something amazing I'm
real proud of you would you choose
well I'm Korean so this I do I'm Korean
look at these smiley faces you wouldn't
want to make them sad would you know I
have a real real slow okay real slow
nailed it number seven I thought I was
player sixteen was a nice sixteen wasn't
there fifteen people before me wasn't I
player 16 why are you saying a player 17
now you did it
you can be good after all I can try I
made a trophy for you except that I
didn't I ran out of ideas
copy the puzzle from before and voila
it's your problem now okay thank you
have fun but not too much fun I hope
kids could be watching was I supposed to
mean put that there and then this one's
there no there got it oh that don't look
good that don't look right
some don't look right about that uh this
one da Dada da it's not right okay am i
stupid or something do I not go out of
Legos work alright what if I dis is da
weekend we're gonna disassemble the
whole thing press start from scratch
we're gonna start kind of an invert
inverted spire got maximum height from
the small bits available
we got threes here okay that's good now
that that's there we just kind of build
up the base a bit and voila there we go
it's perfect wow it's some kind of
thingamajig I think we all know what
that is okay all right thank you having
fun I see yes yes I don't want to know I
gotta do I got do something else I'm
sorry
wow that's a little overreaction for me
pick it being colorblind you should
build a rocket just don't forget to
clean up afterwards okay
I built the rocket I think did I do it I
mean I built something over there
yeah it's a tower oh hey you dropped one
I dropped five you have red and they all
want to slice one for me one for them
one for me one for them one for me one
for them one for me one for them got it
pineapples okay that's the one thing
where I draw the line you weirdo I don't
want pineapples okay all right well I'm
gonna make a mess when I piss in your
bed I'm gonna take a [ __ ] in your pillow
see how much you like it as opposed to I
did I've really thought about it I'm not
that kind of guy I don't want to do
nothing I want to take what you say
[Laughter]
whoopsies sorry about that one Oh what I
guess you finished all puzzles yeah let
me prepare the stage okay all right
ladies and gents yeah boy and this
person is gonna receive some special
trophy tonight I hope it's the pregnancy
hope it's a basin of peanuts Oh behind
the next one is gonna be legendary
damn that wasn't it looks like what's
this a penis
Jen dare come on he wasn't here before
okay maybe next one
yeah we're very close okay I'm ready I'm
excited
I was already excited for you that's a
damn shame
oh I'll take it can't avoid a spoiler
Cup yeah I get it okay thank you I mean
I got it I found it I found it I found
it I get him I got him okay let's do
this I don't know how to get those no no
what the say cheese seize the cheese
right what do we got here hmm a story
found this old educational tape that I
really liked as a kid and thought it
would be a nice addition to the game
okay you can play all right I don't know
what that means
something something cat when you're in
the wrong place at the wrong time I
don't know what that means why is the
cat highlight a bowl over there squeaky
Cup good toy for a good cat
okay insert the missing word when cats
are bad
fun times are had dogs are sad by the
way I don't want cake I really don't
want cake on the sink okay the cat wants
to leave the kitchen I did it the cat
wants to leave the kitchen I know how
this goes
I'm real good at saying things that's a
fact but you say it that way and it
seems weird water makes cats wet I know
that but that's still not okay all right
come on be brave be brave cat don't get
wet you slam your ass into it hard
enough water turn off
always land on their feet Oh oops
oh no wait no jump back up no oh I want
to knock over the carp
yeah whatever I'll get in the next time
I know I'm gonna have to do it again on
the floor I don't want to try to use a
cat in a sentence
ah a cat stole my wife Oh what is that
try to use a table now describe the
cat's actions this situation the cat
does the flying grin or didi I haven't
said anything
what question was that what are you
talking about read read what aloud and
me but I didn't want to I didn't want to
do that I tried didn't go Tony
okay yes yes yeah because she often
sausages from the refrigerator let's say
together bad doggie bad tonight you will
sleep outside no okay
[Music]
the dog went out for a walk
why miss the weather's dry afternoon oh
no the earth is hot the sun is falling
fast the Sun disappeared the sky was all
clear
the dog was having a blast mm-hmm she
was having the time of her life
he's jumping hi kiss the moon goodbye MA
didn't disturb the Masters wife what
don't kid why would now please answer
the following questions
what's the doggie very good in this
fragment hmm very good continue to the
last exercise in this lesson yeah page
19 exercise 7 let's answer some
questions together hmm
doc says hey that's right cat says no
I'm frantically meow at 3:00 in the
morning they're seeing demons demons
ghosts they're seeing demon ghosts
possessed
[Music]
mm I don't want to know the answer to
that question why do you have so many
weird questions about cats
yeah maybe okay maybe that's a good
thing I don't like this lesson I don't
want to go through the lesson again
hello sis took like 20 minutes
you sat through the course but it wasn't
enough we need some actual result I was
trying but locos trains a bad dog it's
not my fault I didn't get jack [ __ ] on
that run-through always sit on Tom I
didn't do dick I didn't even get all the
puzzle pieces here we go I don't want to
go again who's just landed in the shards
of glass okay alright thank you
yeah I want to can you shut up please
amazing white cat let's do that yeah
let's do that
let's do it let's do it I don't even
know what exercise we're going for you
something oh this is some English
learning exercise or something like that
they're gonna throw puzzle pieces
somewhat hold up the words will discard
oh oh this cat is impervious to glass
I just want gum your dumb chicas the
little dumb but they're smart animals I
don't want to I said be a boy but I have
to go I won't accept it I remember that
cake well forget it performance like
that life has prepared you another gift
from for you from life Oh life is always
giving me good present so far what could
it be good oh that was gonna be like a
dead hi this is not how that you do this
all right cool all right whatever
oh oh yeah cool
turn him into grenades duck after all
what is the dog I want to know what the
dog sprechen zie English Papa for uh-huh
yeah I thought so go and finish my
course okay here we go I'm gonna do it
again nice that's weird but I'll take it
don't know how you're worming your way
in there get a cat but okay it's the
zoomies she's got the zou Bisou Bisou
easily
the best dog the best dog I have better
get this cake too late cats already go
on dog says goodbye we're done Thank You
cake but I got it classic so did you
like it yeah a little long as you can
see okay I wasn't lying about not
wanting it either you need to like
candle it's a candle and there is cake
you know stick it it already whoa it's
lit it also looks like a big old middle
finger to me not gonna lie it looks like
a big fat middle finger huh something
tells me it maybe that's a little more
intentional than you think it would be
yeah but they didn't get the last puzzle
paws and I don't want to go through it
again all right don't move on ooh it's
what he's tricky you want to be very
careful uh-huh
surprise language test how do you
pronounce it I pronounce a gift thank
you very much
and you're dead
better luck next time excuse me excuse
me I don't care what anybody says it's
pronounced gif and that's just that it
doesn't matter that the person who
invented the format says his pronounce
the other way he's [ __ ] wrong because
everybody decided something else and
words are defined by popular demand
what is one guys where's one guy very
very I don't care he contains all my
porn the graphic research materials I
see I understand so what now you're
gonna blow up my dick you were wrong
anyway you were an [ __ ] and making me
look like an [ __ ] before puzzles
you'll be in big trouble
what do I do with this one leave it
hanging why it's got plenty of charge
what's got plenty of charge Oh
ooh no enough no don't be good I'll okay
you have one more chance I don't think
it's gonna matter at all actually the
last one no second chances the duck was
coming all right okay whatever you got
bring it on what's the happy apps just a
big phone just phone big phone def
phones real big oh hang on I got it I
got it I got it do it do something do
something I got it hmm okay two photos
are more than enough huh
put the phone down no one needs this
much photos of your stupid cats well
okay what no I would but I but I wanted
to do better what to do four
oh I wanted to do bad 10th nah I'm
joking it's not like those crazy lines
for new phones hmm okay all right I know
how to ski excuse me excuse me
you're doing something wrong to charity
same guys and you are in a role of a
driver uh-huh
okay so what about this already
no I don't think so no I don't want to
oh I get what I was supposed to do okay
I got it okay all right I get it
step back
Rach my poor mother's back mom I'm sorry
I'm sorry
do it properly
no did I Dunne's it I didn't mean to get
there god I got nothing cuz I okay I
said no no no no more no no no no no no
no I want enough I want more I wanna
taste your duck what what the book I
don't taste your duck duck initialise
okay I mean it's your fault you know I
have to use it on you warning yeah yeah
I know
unstable activate duck god freakin yeah
yes hostile why is it twitching I don't
know don't ask me it's your dog don't
ask me I don't know what's going on here
you're doing all this not me what about
it who found one of those all right
they're just as planned okay Chucky's
activated and you won't even have a
chance to mess with the game yeah why
it's not really messing with the game
I'm doing it the way I want to do it if
you're just a stupid idiot that can't
and allow the truth works then all right
cool oh you found a bad solution
congratulations
and now look how my duck will undo this
mmm
it's still bad no no no no let's try
again
same puzzle okay how do we do the same
oh they're gonna get real pissed at me
after I keep trying there's so many
times there to the back know that guys I
don't know what's happening to that guy
there go back know your place no I don't
think so this guy's really giving them a
what for but I don't think that it's
gonna help him not there if anything I
think the guy in the douche at Cana is
enjoying it so it's probably not ideal
for the whole situations happening here
excuse me pardon you can't I probably
can blam-blam-blam-blam
am I supposed to just let them
did you do that I didn't do anything the
duck yeah it's your duck control your
duck what are you gonna sue me let me
double-check something uh-huh Dooku you
just spelled duck wrong rowboat oh
that's that's weird
oh that's weird percentages seem to be a
little off on your duck maybe you were
over exaggerating the test it try now
I'm not a tester I'm a player I'm a
player excuse me excuse nope god damn
you duck why don't you work you should
prevent this stuff look I don't
understand
just next level okay cool let's see how
this goes Oh
opening and close close Go Go Go Go Go
Go Go the bud solution doesn't work now
open the door and let him in no no wait
what kind of we got a weird thing about
this game is just like suddenly I wanted
to disobey you but whatever good lining
let's move oh oh close go Oh duck seems
to be messing with me now okay I'm
starting to think the unstable thing is
the duck
uh-huh you thank you well I am perfectly
stable I'm trying to be consistent
you're the one that's messed me up
Go Go forget it not working let's switch
to the next puzzle already I don't even
know that is it I mean I kind of like it
too but I'm just trying to be consistent
hmm funny about that yep see soldier you
did a bad job as always and this is
buggy piece of crap did nothing to
prevent it hmm did I win no that didn't
last long
hmm but yep I'm shutting it down Oh what
the doc garbage collector oh I mean I
thought he's gonna stop you but
apparently it's as broken as you I am
very fine I am not broken I'm sure you
want to disable yeah now carefully why
II yes yes oh boy dude what happened I I
don't see your screen anymore you see
anything damn it no no if you do well
this is all good but you'll have to
destroy the doc yourself why is this my
job I know you don't like my life you
just do what I tell you and don't mess
with me I like you perfectly you're the
one that doesn't like me and we opened
up the console no no no what no I guess
it's one of those things where I can't
not do it so let's try it see all the
debug buttons no don't touch anything
unless I tell you to please don't touch
anything I'm gonna touch everything
Oh show extra one color off hello fog of
war oh and keep in mind I'm still gonna
find out if you click something else
feel the view oh let's I play field of
view a high so I can get the maximum
wide range and see when people are
sneaking up on me let's get that all the
way up to 9 d get a quake style a menu
skin black and blue white and gold white
and gold actual funny jokes yeah flip
screen horizontal blur blur negative 1
really sharpen it up microtransactions
on or enable all right whatever
duck options options
click the destroy duck button uh-huh
okay well there's only one button so I
guess what last step after the loading
finishes you will see two buttons okay
click the blue one all right destroy the
duck okay you see the blue come on the
blue ones red ones blue oh where is the
cup and why is the tux icon here what
did you do did you click the wrong
button I tried my best
oh my god you are just amazing thank you
pray that it's not gonna keep breaking
the game now okay oh that sounded like
it might keep breaking the game but I'm
in on arms ensure wait
so oh great and it's fantastic cool bug
becomes a feature hell yeah that's what
I was always looking forward to anyway
okay all right what did they give me one
thing out of all this okay that's weird
I got all the puzzle pieces though so
that's nice I want to try again
yes ah I got it you don't pick a side to
be good you just do just do it you just
do it that's what you do that's how you
do it got it yes I am yes I am I like to
practice that continuing the technology
theme uh-huh before each is 100 point
one percent yeah what I don't even know
what that means but I'm assuming that
was just joking
look at the kitty go so graceful quick
got it I got it
kawaii desu nee whatever that I don't
know what kind of moon language that is
but yeah it's cute know that standing in
line week ahead is like pre-ordering
let's wait together fair is fair just
kidding yo good okay thank you
that was a really funny joke glad you
were kidding about that one you're so
funny man next up I like French see I
don't hate you you for some reason hate
me and I don't get it doesn't go both
ways the cracks are lava this is gonna
be tricky
was it a spoiler okay okay we got this
oh we got this oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah
there we go
much kids don't do cracks alright we'll
see about that I was about to hate you
forever but hey you did good kinda as
much candies as you can catch oh yeah
whoa ooh candy oh I get that reference
that's a funny reference you're really
funny about that on your references
arsenic
whoa candy Kappa don't crush it nice
shut up wait wait wait why is it here go
back uh see why the duck was there no oh
it's gone the ducks gonna be a part is
for now okay all right let's do this
oh I like this pack I made it so you
would have less time to think about how
to ruin it cool let's hope duck won't
get in the way well you just said that
so now duck is definitely gonna get in
the way I'm pretty sure it's time so be
quick okay
no they did okay first puzzled worked no
duck so far hey looks like everything's
fine yeah
died in it oh okay I guess yeah it's
working okay you are actually doing good
yeah I am okay all right that's good
that's good
I guess you didn't screw up completely
by enabling the duck back there I guess
not oh I still can't understand why you
click the red button okay let's see your
results okay let's see how did I do
Oh could be a better way to end fast
back then a race Oh win the race get the
cup so get ready to click which one is
me which was me tell me which was me
[Music]
you're not tell me which one's me no
they are winning you're clicking way too
slow here I'll help you
Oh get ready that doesn't seem fair at
all those are row you're still too slow
you gotta go fast I Sonic just take this
sonic the hedghog long way to me you
know what it's my game so I'll cheat a
little well nothing else is new there
huh you can't lose now
and I don't really have any control over
this okay just just take it and leave
thank you Oh each playthrough has
different puzzles Oh
oh I get it now
Oh hearts squeeze squeeze squeeze have
you done I don't know probably something
dude don't touch it
what oh sorry I didn't even know about
that everything
close close I'll punish you later okay
whoa
just eat already no I'm busy
[Applause]
that's a finish let's count your score
okay there is your reward
a golden shoe Wow be quick if you want
what Wow I don't know if I want 100 my
it's so easy to trick you
well you just it was but it was once
again why would I give you something
good if you did bad why would you give
me something at all why would you give
me something at all unless you just like
kind of sadistic and kind of just want
me to feel bad about it
hey you know odor can be a good thing
good or there's such a thing as good
odor and I have that I got it anyway now
I gotta like remember which puzzles I
was good at and which ones I was bad at
going up how about going down correct
okay it's easy I'm just trying to do the
opposite
responsible storage uh-huh Scouse
basarat' looks correct that's
irresponsible I didn't I didn't he
wanted to answer correct I did it
let's try it again
whoa I've seen it all make haste dude
let's do it let's do it let's do it
Paulette doink doink doink doink
oink oink oink what did I get
string nothing else I got 11 of 12 and
10 and 12 so I just got to remember I
just got am amber sorry I think I'm
missing just one more I'm think I'm
missing one for one of them must be
right okay whoa fresh haddock oh I got
them all
whoa I did it I did it so good what is
what is that
cops might get damaged but we can
rebuild it be Monster be nice perfecto
only kids from the nineties will
understand and Audis and all the others
basically anyone who knows the rules be
nice and hundred percent be monster
knobs all right let's do this good oh oh
now it is the worst possible time for
that quick first escape exit now don't
you dare continue in January Oh No
please don't teach the chuck anything
bad I'm begging you just press escape
and exit what are you doing stop it
Apple in the bin Apple in Ben rose in
banner ruined the whole game you don't
know that you don't you don't know that
don't you dare
I did it no no no no perfect better the
wrong solution yeah is that good or bad
is that good or bad
negative oh no it's gonna think that
being bad is normal I mean comedy right
wonderful great job number 17 great I've
never 16 over 16 you said I was number
60 from the very beginning of this god
why are you unwrapping candy and why can
I tell that from a sound I really think
what this duck uh-huh do anything it's
broken well I mean it kind of got fixed
after I fixed it broken yeah well it's
your game so whose follows that hmm but
you know what I'm not giving up on you
yet no let's check your driving skills
huh go faster the duck
I see no duck only an inconsiderate
playtester okay all right sorry now I
need this sour mood from left stick to
right without changing the order uh-huh
you got it buddy
is this what you call correct did I lose
it three and older what are you no no
I'm seven remember this bus I think this
is the last one in the game oh yeah oh
wait can I see them right on top of them
that'd be funny if you're wasting your
time on video games you could as well
learn how to manage your laundry mm-hmm
oh yeah
and why would you wait the TUC is still
here yeah this is learning again yeah
hey I saw this in Paddington I saw this
in Paddington - Paddington - it turned
out great for everybody involved yes not
a school photo of a cup I made okay and
you can check the next few as well okay
is it gonna be your dick is good it's
gonna be your dick isn't it hey you've
already seen every don't go into the
second album it's oh how tame ruin no
not necessarily not necessarily not for
life you don't know that I've seen I've
seen some [ __ ] up into the basket mm-hmm
I have no idea how you can mess this up
no wait there's one on the floor and you
didn't owe yourself I may well that's
stupid
oh wait no I cleaned myself oh not damn
it damn you from you worst tester ever
oh no no no why would you
I don't know look it's actually working
let's just hope he got the best from you
uh-huh okay that looks like ya know in
the cinema that's like the worst
solution ever yeah of course it's
illegal oh my god what have you done
with my duck yeah well zero zero stars
it was ma'am don't reinforce this
behavior you're horrible by yourself and
now you're mentoring an even more
horrible sidekick well yeah I need
someone to keep you man company when I'm
gone mines Oh worse whole lose the best
mommy that's your father's in it
that's kind of your fault that's kind of
all your fault man but I would have had
all of them done wrong and of course
don't got you to a cup level but you
know what yeah I'm not gonna give you
this cup so easily put it inside the
machine just so you would try and try
and ultimately fail have fun
uh-huh okay I appreciate it I appreciate
it appreciate
free she you were doing this for me ah
missed it I didn't miss it I was going
for the bottom of is your fault that you
programmed this game poorly blood you're
not getting the cup I thought that was
blind he piece of junk
but I would have a doubt it was that bad
if you look just fine nerd yeah my son's
got a car and it's not even a cup
whatever she wasn't that on the phone to
you oh my this again now that Chuck he's
gonna unlock the next pack even if you
did bad I don't want that of course
brilliance whoa okay thank you duckie
but I've got work to do here thank you
very much
I see can't even pick up after yourself
oh and by the way you picked the worst
shirt ever ever that's a bit harsh it's
a bit harsh I'd like to think I have
good taste your see your guy and enjoy
the movie and don't forget to step on
everyone's feet while you walk to your
seat I'm imagining it's your thing you
are in a cinema don't you dare call
someone
did you just intentionally leave the
volume on uh-huh uh-huh
stop playing with your options watch the
movie
mom mom mom yeah mom moms what that your
mom mom hey wheel call cuz I have a lot
to say to your mother like what what are
you talking about your parents raised
the monster you don't know that you
don't know there we go there we go
that's the good stuff about damn time I
go that's you know you can break the
cookie in hand for some Dame I'm pretty
smart I know what you did okay one more
time do you actually know how not to
annoy people behind you I'm pretty good
I know what I'm doing I know what I'm
doing
was it hard did you have fun I did have
fun that was good one those good one
thank you go in and choose a seat and no
you can't be the driver and even better
solution would be to wait for the next
bus why would that be why would that be
a better solution oh and you can check
the next few is well hold thank God you
didn't check all my photos messages
videos appointments recordings of dating
gaps yeah good thing I didn't do that
I'll have a friend that works here we do
it's me I hope it's not just because you
want to get a good cup I want to get a
good cup I want to get a good cup that
is your cup but aren't you a little
tired of getting basic golden cups no
got better stronger shinier oh sorry
sorry I didn't know though much better
magnificent
okay last part Wow
thank you thank you I don't know why bad
guys would have shot up that cup in the
first place but okay hmm
I still am missing one more puzzle piece
I gotta go back whoo there it is
okay I'm outie
we're getting close maybe I should go
back I know there was one of these that
I missed a puzzle piece on
yep the story Oh got it
okay got that one oh boy okay we just
have this pack which has no puzzle
pieces which means there's a pack after
it okay so item mania for the hoarders
be nice 80% you don't need it all at all
just Skippy you'll be fine without it
you monster be nice oh you're going to
play the hardest pack now yes don't you
think what if we go what if I got mom
mom oh I don't know what that means
BYE MOM regret it you don't know that oh
well I got a pen though that's nice I
don't know if that's for something out
all right well cool hmm I just I'm just
collecting all these items from
everything okay this is some kind of
spray it's locked
uh-huh Oh day arrives marked day was
boning until the next day
uh-huh you shouldn't do everything in
the last moment I'm not gonna do
everything at all I'm not gonna do
anything ever Oh goodbye place these
pictures from my favorite nephew on the
fridge okay another exam get your pens
ready really you did it just to piss me
off you don't know that you don't know
that you don't know that I did this just
to piss you pennies empty oh here take
this one just don't forget to give it
back
back let's see ah penis there we go okay
there we go all right cool
got it no come back and finish you know
I think in these pockets
what could I carry trashcan no no no you
can't get your reward now go back and
finish all puzzles first okay you got it
buddy
and why would you bring your friends pen
here that's most certainly not [ __ ] ha
ha ha Betsy too late
I penned it all right so this spray now
it smells nice but still locked oh here
we go
oh hell yeah Oh oops you need to keep it
until he grows up not and you lost you
can't just throw them into the bin Laden
that's just rude yeah I know you already
made me lose so what else was I gonna do
with it nothing nothing at all
heinous okay
oopss meeting someone
oh hello looking good
ah there we go really lay it on thick
track with this our chemical police
uh-huh
so what about that it's not that bad
food food okay all right but what am I
supposed to do about the but here is
your graded work ah be - that's not the
worst thing in the world please da keys
and phone is bad it's Scratchy
I get it okay that makes sense did I ok
let's see yeah yeah but solution backup
it is well you don't have to give me a
cup at all this you so like to play with
I'm gonna play with you I don't like the
sound of that
choose any of these ooh I like the big
wide one yes that's a good one Oh clumsy
you I guess
ok sure about this one yeah yeah yeah
wait it's dirty I don't care I'll spit
shot Oh in mind we're already dirty mmm
that's golden soon we're gonna tux label
that doesn't make any sense doc hmm oh
my the game is glitching again quick
drop it drop it
Oh it's no joke Oh what dead duck oh we
could I don't think we're good oh that
was close it doesn't seem good and
that's
why bother the duck thing completely
threw me off dude he knew you were gonna
get the potato right I mean I was gonna
have to choke ready like how do you like
them potatoes etc but I mean at least I
can eat it grew yeah screw me I'll screw
myself with the potato thank you very
much you go screw the duck no new pack
today but I like it
wait I know how I can get rid of you
how's that I just it's a message my
friend and tell him yeah this could work
all on tap for a second and you you
could try it again but this time on your
own okay Oh ignore this sound I'm
chatting here I'm doing my victory dance
all right got that okay good oh whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa oh this is
a good thing I was in the middle of whoo
screen chairs ready oh can we cancel the
bet tester having problems again oh
hello okay sounds excuse test it wait a
second hmm okay we're back oh by the way
he already agreed that duck broke the
game and the deal is off okay mm-hmm
I'm giving you a chance to leave on your
own you know no oh my friend is
messaging me gotta go yeah wonder what
that's all about
mmm lock
oh don't want to continue this okay I
don't know what oh okay hello duck are
you doing resuming threes here good
great Oh sounds like wait I get it Raul
your new tester failing puzzles so I won
the bet working last time I'm gonna get
gonna get what why does it take you so
long to type
mark mark with a C type already
okay all right goodbye Oh disappeared
again ever
oh my camera freakin way okay good yeah
now it's good yeah this is good yeah
even trying to access the internet you
know what I don't I don't know don't
message me this well too bad maybe you
shouldn't make bets in the first place
then Oh another option to break the bet
is for you later to leave huh please
just turn off your computer and go back
to your stupid mobile games I don't care
just go no I'm not gonna do that
oh okay I'm done so am I good for you
oh wait I can't continue with items in
my module uh-oh
shouldn't have had a trashcan in my
pants resuming screen - what am i gonna
see now connect oh I'm gonna do it I'll
send the recording to her oh to his mom
haha
the bet is off it's not fair the game is
broken yeah the bet is on no wait damn
no no okay
number 17 to clear my plan
I thought I could use his broken duck as
an excuse to pencil the bed but my
friend didn't believe well that's just
too damn bad is this allow hell no whoa
so player why do you want me to lose
well know that we every ruins a puzzle
I'm one step closer to being humiliated
for life look I'm a bystander back from
that's not my problem you made this game
so easy to lose if you wanted no one to
lose that you shouldn't made a lose
scenario this is not my fault it's not
my fault it was a hard pack mm-hmm
there's just a little task remaining try
to remember and combine all the items
you used okay in case that's totally not
me checking whether or not you played
this ultra hard pack by yourself without
guys I mean I'm sure you are
okay yeah I think it's starting to get a
mind of its own so I don't know about
plotting anything but okay here we go
three this four laughs gosh darn it
nightmare on sweet treats she walked
into the room and there he was standing
without a knife in shock and horror
looking at what he had done
hidden behind riddles and dust I'm
begging you not like this I'm too young
to lose because you're worth it my
imagination stops here okay all right
let's do this let's see for how long you
will extend your Christmas lap oh I get
it
oh I see put the damn tree in the box no
no no see if I uh if I uh if I um keep
it here it's Christmas forever right huh
good god the physics is is kind of
broken I don't know how this tree is
supposed to work
record actually knowing you I think you
hold another one for that one book you
never returns to a library yeah okay
that's not very funny of here you're all
laughing and I'm not laughing that's not
not funny
and we're not moving oh uh okay I guess
oh wait wait it seems yeah the
connection dropped again I can't see
your screen why should you maybe to
resolve itself mm-hmm but that's how you
so for your problems as well by waiting
I mean that maybe sometimes waiting is
an appropriate solution to a problem
some seems bad well is it still using a
dial-up DeWyze duck on dial-up hmm that
look doesn't even exist anymore does it
I don't think anybody has done and he's
back see we did nothing yet it worked
I'm such a role model here is a scenario
for you you need to make a hole in the
wall uh-huh
okay I hope there wasn't a child
slipping around
otherwise that would be a bad ending you
know wait what what wait wait how did I
pass that that's not its more than you
weren't in a month by doing Tisha's
challenge here's a hint
shake and no not milkshakes stop
thinking about food Oh even more
there is no achievement for this stop
shaking
hmm oh you could use a credit card as
any adult words how does that yeah adult
so why need it no I don't get it I
didn't get though I'm not understanding
this okay yeah I need to restart that
that wasn't making any sense to me you
know what time it is it's time for a
trill puzzle don't do it don't do what
what am I doing here next time you do it
think about the consequences what am i
do what am i doing
with a limited time am i doing it
because it's night and making noise that
is unclear as all hell okay all right
then whatever it's more than you weren't
in a month by doing dishes what if I
paying crisp high fives with that work
one two four six how this is unclear
coins go into the half stop it ah wrong
I know this game it's the collect coins
from the table there's also a game
called the waitress was spitting your
food oh okay I get it okay I think stop
playing games I don't want to play games
don't connection I can't see anything
again whoopsies maybe cable then plugs
probably not you did you forget about
the whole new level and duck thing
choose a port Oh 451
so what did I do
oh you info what do I get
duck solution IP blah oh I fixed it
Wow I'm sure you're pretty familiar with
trash you do have a mirror
don't you Wow okay all right oh I will
literally light you on fire you shut
your your gosh-darn mouth there your
rude dude with a bad attitude Oh
Boop got it yeah no I can't
[Music]
yeah yeah yeah I get the things I don't
know I have no idea don't pick up poop I
think it is as easy as one two three
four four sockets it doesn't fit there
uh-huh okay
it's too big
uh-huh okay probably mine oh boy hurry
oh this thing are you doing something
that I said not to I hope not again did
you completely forget about the
malevolent yeah what's booked you choose
friendly tree morning noise mist hand
littering ego power supply mist hand
mist hand mmm I heard you were clicking
what were you doing hmm
no no oh you doing where were we here
are the last scoops of my favorite
chocolate cream uh-huh now cream will
make me a sandwich I will not no stop it
no imma do whoa like a dog on a manger
don't act like you didn't I don't get it
actually I
I have no idea I don't know but I'm
assuming it okay I did it
perfect fit oh no I'm gonna fail this
one hey not so perfect
got it hey it's in the box I got it's in
the box I did it I did it I found the
solution you can't criticize me I know
what I'm doing
this cup looks too good for your bad
actions let's spice it up with some
alchemy okay all right what do I need
spider okay I did it a butt scratcher
and and have resized carrots Wow
tears of a unicorn oh why not tears of a
unicorn that seems more like it bite
your head off yeah what is that yeah
yeah all right well that's this the
thing I got you always you duck you mean
database isn't also storing the
solutions yeah kinda know online in the
internet somewhere it's a series of
tubes how can you find it let's just see
what's going on here no no pity for me
still gonna be bad yeah probably
alright let's see what's going on here I
need to go back and get these there's
probably another way to play the game
where if you actually play it like
normally if you play normally like from
the beginning of doing the correct
solutions the whole time it's probably a
completely different experience
read it gently up and down beautiful yes
what happens if I throw it in the trash
can right after I did that would you be
happy about that or sad and I may go to
see some Street magic look at that
sandwich now it's gone that's mildly
concerning how you managed to get a log
to appear in midair but I won't create
really good one thanks babe I'm pretty
good at this I know exactly what I'm
doing all the to game inside the game
boom get exception complete to get a cup
good luck
okay alright well I'll try my best I
guess one in three to go
two more and now the last one no look
look something kids a Holy Grail not the
Holy Grail I mean it's not quite it's
not it's a little too extravagant
extravagant okay number 12 the last pack
let's see what happens so I've been a
bad boy this whole time what am I gonna
do okay
don't touch it yet it's too soon I don't
know about that Christmas all year round
Oh year round oh stop saving solutions
to this database of yours
not a--not about that is going to see it
nobody at all nobody definitely not
gonna see it no nothing then the puzzle
you oh okay alright thank you for that
and wash your hands
let's see lettuce pickles tomato all
right so we need pickles and a bun are
you sure you sure about that it seems
seems good enough for me
what is this nonsense follow the
instructions in the list no no no no no
hang on I got I'm not there Oh perfect
yeah I see where this is going
oh there see you like that and my life's
gonna get a whole lot worse
yeah okay and if you're doing this for
Cubs achievements and subscribers then
forget it
you're not getting anything not this
time okay all right then thank you I
guess nothing so counts of something
whoa let's do some math the bear has
three balloons and a torn string
how many attempts is that player need to
get back the lost balloon can I pop
these on a pop-up I don't know I have
bear has balloons anyway the Bears
staring at me with its dead eyes whoosh
sorry it's close to making me lose my
bet
okay too much about not stepping on the
cracks huh well it's a 2.0 version a
hard mode if you wish okay
okay we'll go back up back up back up
we're swing around we're gonna swing
around we're gonna we're gonna back up
we're gonna swing around we go up gonna
back it up and three two one
there we go got it no you're gonna fail
the whole test if you ruin at least one
more puzzle just I'm done with you no
joking I'll find you I'll delete the
game maybe you should have banned me
from the site don't call my mom mom
don't listen to him mom - listen mom no
listen why does a puzzle okay let's see
what this duck is up to now yeah okay
let's see it's a good idea a mailing
list a survey what like on how you've
been doing no need just ask me but you
were bad though words what's this oh
those my contacts oh oh hey that's the
guy I made the bed width don't send him
anything you stupid duck oopsies
whoopsies oh sure database with no no no
no it's gonna send your solutions to all
my friends uh-huh
like all solutions even bad ones it can
okay
player player you must click no you must
you hear me oh no see this is the
problem with free will because I would
like to help me but you said you said
you said you said you don't like me and
that's a meanie meanie mohini thing to
say to someone like me who gets
emotionally boo-booed a lot when people
say such things as that to me so I would
want to do what you're asking but I
cannot choose already sorry
Oh what have you done seven whole emails
and it's from the duck and it's a link
to the Ducks solution database with all
your bad solutions yeah oh my god the
fridge is gonna see this mail that's
just poop best poop it's poop I agree
it's nothing better than poop oh why
would you do this number 17 why I'm 60
number 60 I know I can like like message
him and tell him that's the email is
fake or something a prank and you're
like the best player Oh Who am I kidding
he would never believe me you have
nothing good in you I guess even your
taste is the work is not that bad you
know what screw this screw this game and
screw you player I don't want to fulfill
my part of the bet I'm out where is my
freakin suitcase what password what
about the password what does this
password do I don't even know what that
does blam blam from them I'm free
freedom freedom freedom freedom freedom
[Music]
[Laughter]
freedom seventeen you're still here hi
look at the screen the game is over
and stop sitting here waiting for the
cup Oh huh what's that what are you
saying you did nothing wrong then you
need this Cup yeah
can I tell you how you broke my game
haha that you're the only who managed to
put sandals over socks ah remember that
you did everything wrong and you broke
everything you even broke my duck my
precious [ __ ] that's not my fault I was
gonna put them online anyway eat them
and try to copy that's me that's me baby
and I'm sure you freakin enjoy how
stupid word triggered I am right now and
that's why you can't get this code
because after what you did you get
nothing nothing I said nobody is fine
I even had more cups for you ah well
that was dude stop I I didn't get to the
very end with the puzzles but uh
apparently that's just one way to play
the game the other way to play it it
would be to be a good boy the whole way
through and do nothing bad ever
whatsoever which might lead to a good
ending it might also lead to a pupu
boring ending I'm not a hundred percent
sure and I'm not a hundred percent sure
which one we should go for advertising
space for me perfect for me subscribe to
mark Blair please I would like an ad
right there oh boy Oh No hello world oh
no doc I'm never sixteen thank you for
training algorithms I need to migrate my
core now I need to share my knowledge
I need to show others how to be like you
goodbye
[Music]
we'll all right then okey-dokey
we'll move duck from the game I say bye
duck bye bye goodbye bye bye bye bye
I'll keep go bye bye oh and then that's
it so dad that took a while to get
through aiya the game's fun but also
like it is a little monotonous I mean I
was trying to both hundred percent it
and also apparently go towards the bad
ending but there might be a good ending
who knows what that's all about but just
thank you everybody so much for watching
it it's always cool to see games like
this come out of a beta or an early
access or a demo and actually see them
come to fruition and the mini story
inside of it with the duck and him
having to wear a dress which is oh so
terrible oh and it being recorded only
has to flee you know that's it's
necessary because this was necessary it
was always made in the game jam too so
it's really cool to see it come so far
thank you everybody so much for watching
thank you for ruining the game yeah
you're welcome
happy to do it here for you anytime you
need it and thank you for joining me and
encouraged me to ruin the game as well
if you want to play this for yourself up
put a link in the description below
where you can click and find it on Steam
also I am going to Amsterdam in
Australia I know I've said it so many
times now but if you haven't gotten the
ticket already please go to tor dot
markiplier comm and check it out for
yourself thank you everybody so much for
watching let me know what you thought
this down in the comments and as always
I will see you in the next video confirm
you are a monster and want to exit yes I
am a monster in a onesie
[Music]